the first thing that I want to get a
sense of is where this project came from
where what inspired you and Chris to
write this and what was the genesis of
it sure well my co screenwriter Chris
Prakash brought this world to my
attention I honestly did not know I had
never heard the term the hidden homeless
I didn't know there was a situation
going on and kissimmee in Orlando and
which families were living in motels
budget motels right outside of of the
parks and he was sending me news
articles his mother had recently
relocated there so and he was also
sending me photos from his trips down
there the more I read into it I was I
think I was drawn to that same
juxtaposition as the journalists were of
children growing up in these motels
outside of what we consider the happiest
place on earth for children now at the
same time him and I we've always been
talking about wanting to make a film
about children
I am personally extremely inspired and
influenced by the little rascals every
one of my films have a wink towards Hal
Roach is our gang and if you think about
what the little rascals were there were
these you know these comics shorts from
the 20s and 30s set against the Great
Depression and most of the characters in
our gang we're living in poverty and yet
it shine it was what it was doing this
was focusing on the joy of childhood and
the humor and the heart and and and I
thought this might be a nation yes
imagination and I thought this might be
an opportunity here to sort of make a
present-day little rascals and and and
you know focus on the comedy of it
that's important as an as an
entertainment medium the film is to
entertain an audience and and and have
audiences laughing with these kids but
at the same time hopefully leaving them
with this you know perhaps an issue they
did not know about and and shining a
light on what's happening in the u.s.
right now so talk about how this film
was shot and what equipment you used and
and to get the look of this and
especially you've got a purple motel and
you
got the big orange and you've got
Florida skies which I'm sure very
unpredictable because we've got clouds
and rain and you ended up having it all
in there so talk about those conditions
I mean it was very clear from the
beginning talking to Shawn that we
wanted to tell the story from the
children's point of view and it was kind
of our search was to you know to get
back to this more naive or young people
you were things you know even if it's a
seedy hotel it it's still you know
magical and even though reality is not
great used to you know as a kid you
don't see that you just see surprise and
you know you see the world with
different eyes so that was our objective
all along um we had obviously never
being dogmatic I think we approached
most sequences with a very open mind and
heart but that was kind of our leading
you know intention so camera low you
know what the kids hide and then and
then also kind of like you know we
wanted to pump up the colors a little
bit to make it seem a bit more magical
and kind of really translate kids POV
you know so but still keeping it real
you know so it was a fine line I guess
to walk you know still maybe having
people see this movie and you know how
real is this how is this a documentaries
but at the same time still have a little
bit of that magic and a little bit of
that surprise and just wonder in the
image a little bit you know dreamy I
guess or ice cream I think we we call it
it many times you don't have a film look
like ice cream kind of I believe most of
your cast was either fairly
inexperienced or or even had never made
a movie before can you talk about that
sure
a casting process and the mixing and the
working with non actors or or in
experienced actors right right thank you
yeah I'd love to I like to divide it
into three categories a seasoned actor a
first timer and a non-professional
because when I call my first-timers and
non-professional it hurts them getting
more work in this town because sometimes
the industry here is not professional
they think unprofessional the non
professionals were basically people that
we've found
in the moment or residents of the motel
or just locals that we said get involved
in this one scene crowd scenes etc
sometimes working them in a little bit
more hope you know but then they're
first-timers and that I I apply that to
to Tamela to Bri to all the kids they
were all found in different ways I
mentioned the casting call earlier I
wanted the kids to be local it was very
important to me
not only for the accent the subtle the
slight accent but also so that they
could go home at night and feel
comfortable we were taking their summer
away from them and essentially so we
tried to make it a summer camp for them
and and so they all came from casting
calls except for valaria who plays Jancy
in the film her best friend I found her
in target one night I loved doing Street
casting on my own sometimes we also had
another wonderful street caster by the
name of Patti Wiley and but we were
always on the lookout and I just was
going to target one night trying to get
milk and there's this beautiful little
girl with red vibrant red hair and I
gave the mother her mother Eve my card
and I said please have her come in for
an audition and I think he was really
freaked out at first but she she'd go
with me and everything was okay and then
Bria who plays Hayley in the film yeah
she came through social media I actually
found her on Instagram which I know is
very unorthodox but know there's
something about her I really believe in
this girl I've been watching her videos
on Instagram she's making me laugh she's
she's already putting herself out there
so I know there was gonna be no she's
not gonna be intimidated she's already
an extrovert so I know that she has the
physicality she has the humor she's
self-deprecating let's just give her her
a chance and she flew to Orlando she
rehearsed
I mean auditioned with the kids and we
knew from that moment that we were we're
gonna go with her and then and of course
Willem came through you know the
agency's in Carmen Cuba who cast the
film and so you know there were we just
try to mix it up with casting so you
told me that you shot on 35mm meter film
and
the same time I want to talk to the two
of you about the script a little bit it
seems to me like there are moments that
first of all most of it feels very
spontaneous or real at this but at the
same time there are some moments where
you know the filmmaker in me says that
was probably an improv line how tightly
scripted was this and talked a little
bit to about I was sitting there through
the entire film waiting for something
horrible to happen which was even though
there were moments of levity this was a
dark living situation so talk about
balancing out what your audiences were
expecting and the surprise and and
finding the tone you did well we
actually we had a 102 page screenplay
that evolved over the course of getting
the idea in 2011 all the way to shooting
in last summer and you know working with
Sean's really thrilling for me because
it's not the traditional you write the
script and then he goes and shoots it
you know we're constantly evolving it
right up until your cameras rolling and
we're throwing out lines for the actors
and you know sometimes well his cameras
rolling yeah well his cameras rolling
yeah and you know it creates for a
really spontaneous feel and I love it
because then it kind of helps the
organic you know feeling that you're
describing and then there's other scenes
you know like the perfume scene where
Sean just literally in the script he'll
write you know a couple of lines like
the justin beiber line I think was one
of them you'll smell like Justin Bieber
and then it's just candid camera daki
style where they just go try to sell
perfume and it's this mixture I think
that creates the organic feeling but you
know the ending was always something
that we never wavered from I believe you
know up until that you know the script
changed a lot but that first treatment
always had we knew we were going there
and we knew how that was going to get
darker and darker as it played out so
Alexis I'm told the last scene was shot
on an iPhone and the rest was 35
anamorphic we talked about the iPhone
and why that was used I mean maybe need
to I mean the iPhone I guess our main
reason
stealth palace you know at the same time
you know we there was something special
about that scene where we really wanted
to differentiate it from the rest of the
film and so that just you know that that
worked out perfectly
you know we managed to get in there we
actually Chris actually had us some
t-shirts made to appear like a family
vacation and I was wondering what this
looked like so when you had the iPhone
what what what was that like I mean are
you like this with your fingers did you
have no no just with my hand and wearing
these silly blue t-shirt saying we're
like whatever family and and I'm running
after Brooklyn and and and valaria like
not once but maybe you know 11 times you
know away from the entrance
I don't know thinking Jesus somebody's
gonna suspect at some point that we're
doing you know but no just you know it
was just a group of you know it's like a
family outing and getting some weird
footage there I don't know it's amazing
mm-hmm talk about working with that
particular children and first of all
just that keeping that character of
Monique oh so consistent as well as
dealing with the emotion of those scenes
sure well as I said before Brooklyn
Prince is on a whole other level I
really put her in the same camp as that
Mickey Rooney and Jodie Foster and the
Fanning's she was born to do this
she she's already you know she had
experience coming into this she had done
a few commercials she understands
character and scene even at six years
old but that seemed we had scripted
obviously four tears but we didn't want
to rehearse it we discussed it Samantha
Kwan again the acting coach discussed it
with her mom and they said you know we
talked about her at home and and and and
Brooklyn knows she's gonna put herself
in that place of somebody not being able
to see her friend again so we never had
to go to the place of like Oh think
about your dog who died or anything like
that no she came she came to set that
day very confidence we could see that
and we set up the camera and it was over
Valeria's shoulder in that close-up and
as we started rolling camera that oval
area who still the
hilarya not in her character yet started
saying brooklyn are we gonna have a
sleepover or something along those lines
because they became very good friends on
set and she was having a little bit of
small talk and brooklyn goes valaria I'm
gonna have to focus right now I'm about
to cry and I have to go to another place
I have to concentrate okay she's taking
me seriously next thing you know oh my
gosh she started she started taking it
to a level we didn't even know and I
remember I think you were on my right
and Sam was on my left Samantha and we
were just we were just I think I was
holding Sam's hand and we were just
looking and saying this is an incredible
she's really going there and this is a
quite this is a performance from a child
I've never seen before
and then I wanted to yell cut because I
just couldn't take it anymore but we had
we waited until if she got her last line
out you know goodbye and at that point
cut and like everybody it's like a swarm
of you know crew members everyone
hugging her and she came down and I just
it's just an incredible moment that she
got to that place on her own which I
still am so astonished and I still I'm
so incredibly honored to have worked
with this little girl thank you very
much for being there and thank you for
saying to listen